Do I still take the powder and smoothie when I'm not taking the fenben?
So I think this person had a recommendation that they're on
the fenben four days three days off or something like that
But they're also taking a smoothie with some other things in a maybe some spectra
To maybe grades first so the answer is yes
You still take the smoothie the powder the other things the other days
You just don't put the fenben is all product in it. You only put the fenben is all product in it
The recommended days
So whether it's four days or three days, whatever you just you do the rest of them on all you do all of it
For three days and then you do all but the fenben is all for the other day